madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce samedi 22 septembre
à rennes l'alcool serait à l'origine de
l'incendié de l'immeuble qui a fait dix
blessés graves trois personnes sont
toujours portées disparues un jeune
homme de 21 ans est passé aux aveux il
reconnaît avoir mis le feu à des cartons
alors qu'il était en état d'ébriété
agitation dans le milieu du grand
banditisme à un commando de dix hommes a
attaqué à l'explosif ce matin une
entreprise de transports de fonds des
bouches du rhône plusieurs millions
d'euros à la clé en marge de
l'arrestation du roi de l'évasion pascal
payet les policiers de la brigade de
répression du banditisme ont multiplié
les interpellations
ahmadinejad ne tremble pas pire le
président iranien répond à la communauté
internationale en faisant défiler deux
nouveaux missiles longue portée
voilà pour l'image les mots sont
également radicaux pas question
d'abandonner son programme nucléaire
c'est une des questions des enfants et
des jeunes ados à leurs parents en ce
moment est-ce que je peux avoir un rat
ne soyez pas surpris c'est la mode c'est
une tendance
un phénomène qui vous le verrait mérite
quelques explications
et puis nous terminerons cette édition
avec un coup de projecteur sur les
dernières nouveautés en matière de jeux
vidéo
petits et grands attendent avec
impatience les prochaines sorties
un festival est ouvert ce week-end à
montreuil en banlieue parisienne
mais tout d'abord commençons ce journal
par cette information qui fait quoi
plusieurs affaires similaires en fin
d'après midi une petite fille de 10 ans
a trouvé la mort après avoir été attaqué
par deux chiens à auteuil près de
beauvais dans l'oise
des chiens qui appartiendrait à son
entourage faisons tout de suite un point
sur la situation avec le préfet de
région propos recueillis par julien boom
de chiens qui semble que deux types de
galement dans le jardin du domicile
famille
les chiens se sont jetés sur elle et lui
infliger des blessures morte
il semblerait que là la mère de la
petite fille est assisté impuissantes et
dans l'horreur qui s'est produit dans
quelle pourra sans doute
en parler mais pour l'instant elle est
extrêmement chaud les cieux ont pu être
isolée puisqu'une enquête est en cours
elle était pas semble-t-il de premier ou
de deuxième catégorie ce qu'on appelle
les chiens d'attaqué défense
c'était quand même des chiens d'une
force suffisante et d'une taille
suffisante pour infliger des blessures
mortelles alors fondu c'est donc un
défaut de vigilance qui serait à
l'origine de ce drame quelle que soit la
nature du chien les spécialistes sont
unanimes il ne faut jamais laisser un
enfant seul avec une explication
nathalie cpna ce sont des chiens comme
celui ci qui viennent de tuer une
fillette de 10 ans un dogue allemand un
animal énorme de plus de 80 kg
impressionnant et pourtant réputé peu
agressif mais dans présence d'enfants
tous les chiens surtout quand ils sont
gros peuvent être dangereux
simplement quand on a un chien 35 kg qui
mord ça fait beaucoup de dégâts quel que
soit le type de morsures et on ne laisse
jamais un enfant seul même des enfants
jusqu'à une dizaine d'années avec un
chien car la rame se succèdent quatre
attaques en un mois dont deux mortels en
août dernier un american staffordshire a
tué une petite fille de 18 mois en juin
ce sont deux rottweilers qui blesse
grièvement un petit garçon de deux ans
cette série d attaques de chiens relance
le débat la loi sur les chiens dangereux
et l adapter la ministre de l'intérieur
michèle alliot marie avait demandé
récemment une plus grande fermeté dans
son application
mais contrairement au pitbull ou au
rottweiler les deux allemands ne sont
pas classés comme chiens dangereux
selon un député plus de 70 mille chiens
de défense ne sont soumis à aucune
réglementation
et puis sachez qu'une autre attaque de
chiens dangereux cette fois s'est
produite aujourd'hui en seine saint
denis une jeune femme de 27 ans a été
grièvement blessé par deux rottweilers
il n'aura fallu qu'une vingtaine de
minutes pour que
immeuble situé en plein centre de rennes
s'embrase à l'origine de l'incendié de
jeudi soir trois jeunes âgés de 19 et 21
ans
l'un d'entre eux est passé aux aveux il
a reconnu être en état d'ébriété au
moment des faits ce soir après des
heures de recherches trois personnes
sont toujours portées disparues sur
place jacques devaux et gabriel calmes
hier les pompiers qui s'affairait ce
matin encore dans les ruines de
l'immeuble ont interrompu leur travail
cet après midi le site est devenu trop
dangereux et il va falloir sécuriser les
lieux avant de poursuivre les recherches
les recherches qui deviennent désormais
capital pas personnes doivent être
considérées comme disparues
ces trois personnes deux jeunes filles
un jeune homme se trouvait selon toute
vraisemblance dans un appartement du 5e
étage lorsque l'incendié s'est déclaré
ils auraient été piégées par la violence
du feu qui a détruit l'escalier d'autres
résidents du cinquième étage ont dû plus
de chance
et un homme de 21 ans accompagné de deux
amis a reconnu avoir mis le feu à la
cage d'escalier interpellé en état
d'ivresse lors de l' incendie
il a été déféré au parquet aujourd'hui
une alcoolisation qui a relancé la
polémique temps qui interpelle le maire
de rennes
cet incendie est liée aux nuits
particulièrement alcoolisé du jeudi des
nuits où la police est intervenu
régulièrement faut faire évacuer des
dizaines de jeunes ivres dans les rues
mais selon le maire cette triste
habitude n'est plus d'actualité cette
nuit de jeudi à vendredi
comme les autres au cours de ces
derniers mois a été très calme c'est ce
que la police ne dit et ce que l'on sait
quoi qu'il en soit c'est bien sur fond
d'alcool que le drame s'est noué
l'alcool que l'auteur présumé des faits
présente comme une excuse
il risque désormais de devoir répondre
de la mort possible de trois personnes
l'actualité est également marquée ce
samedi par une agitation autour du
milieu du grand banditisme tout d'abord
un commando d'une dizaine d'hommes a
attaqué au petit matin une entreprise de
transport de fonds à gémenos dans les
boules lieu dans les bouches-du-rhône
attaque très organisés des hommes
fortement armés et qu'ils ont fait
exploser le mur de la salle des coffres
le butin est estimé à plusieurs millions
d'euros le commando est toujours en
fuite
un braquage d'un commando d'hommes armés
hier en espagne le roi de l'évasion
arrêté son nom pascal payet l'homme au
moment de son interpellation était en
compagnie de deux membres du milieu
marseillais voilà deux dossiers pour les
policiers de la brigade de répression du
banditisme
hasard du calendrier ou regain de
violences au sein d'un milieu
traditionnellement actifs début de
réponse avec gérard griesbeck et
caroline libbrecht il n'aura goûté que
deux mois à la liberté
pascal payet de nouveau sous les verrous
après une cavale qui l'a mené jusqu'en
espagne tout s'est arrêté hier après
midi sur le parking de ce centre
commercial dans la banlieue de barcelone
le fugitif condamné à 30 ans de prison
sortait d'un restaurant avec deux
complices mais des policiers espagnols
et français l'attendaient
cela faisait des jours qu'une trentaine
d'enquêteurs le pistaient dans un état
traditionnellement voyons kamal bon il
est très sera son vote il y là il avait
des faux papiers il avait des armes et
de l'argent il avait arrive au dessus
d'une voiture volée c'est à dire la
panoplie habituelle laval 7 heures
chevronnés le 14 juillet dernier prison
de grasse en fin de journée un
hélicoptère s'approchent du toit quatre
malfaiteurs ont des sens des extraits
pascal payet de sa cellule
l'évasion est un coup de maître mais un
camouflet pour la justice et la police
d'autant que l'homme est un récidiviste
sa traque devient dès lors une priorité
absolue avant travailler sur des
relations connus qui sont sont révélés
encore d' enquête et déterminer un noyau
dur dont on pensait qu'ils pourraient
être à l'origine de l'évasion
il y a quelques jours deux complices ont
pris en filature à marseille ils vont
conduire les enquêteurs jusqu'à la
région de barcelone et à pascal payet à
marseille les policiers ont interpellé
une douzaine de personnes dont il faudra
déterminer l'implication dans la cavale
de pascal payet direction l'état lit
maintenant avec une tradition qui a la
vie dure en sicile le pizzo un impôt que
les entreprises ont l'habitude de payer
à la mafia locale
on parle de 10 milliards d'euros ainsi
récoltées par an est bien l'association
des entrepreneurs a décidé d'exclure de
ses rangs ceux qui paient cet impôt
mafieux un choix risqué sur place en
italie
reportage de philippe visseyrias et
karine guillaumin depuis trois semaines
andrea vecchio et protéger les 8es jours
par la police
cet entrepreneur sicilien est devenue le
symbole de la résistance à la mafia cela
fait dix ans qu'ils refusent de se plier
au racket imposé par les clans mafieux
disant qu'il subit menaces et attentats
et dernier en date
les voici des bombes incendiaires dans
ces engins de chantier ulcéré andrea
vecchio a écrit au président de la
république italienne et a raconté le
quotidien des patrons en sicile les
mafieux viennent directement sur les
chantiers et ils nous disent si tu veux
travailler dans ce quartier
doit respecter nos règles ici tu dois
donner de l'argent aux chefs de clans si
tu veux vivre en paix et travailler
tranquillement que tu dois l'histoire
d'andré avec you a poussé le patronat
sicilien à prendre une décision
historique exclure de son organisation
tous les entrepreneurs qui acceptent de
payer les racketteurs on ne peut plus
vivre comme au moyen-âge ou des
entreprises par ailleurs engagé sur les
marchés internationaux sont chez elles
en sicile racketter par des mafieux
analphabètes le racket de la mafia la
plaie de l'économie sicilienne 60 euros
par mois pour un vendeur ambulant
jusqu'à 15000 pour un chantier
d'autoroute ici à catane comme dans le
reste de l'île 70 % des commerçants sont
rackettés dit on mais certains os se
rebeller comme massimo francesco et
angelo trois frères qui ont reconstruit
leur boutique de fruits et légumes
après qu'elle ait été incendié par la
mafia si tu es tu entres dans un cercle
vicieux dont une fois plus jamais sortie
donne la possibilité à ces gens-là de
vivre sur koné d'opale ces derniers
jours rien que sur catane 28 plainte
pour racket ont été déposées pour les
associations anti mafia
c'est le signe que les mentalités sont
enfin en train de changer en sicile dans
24 heures le président ahmadinejad
devrait quitter téhéran pour rejoindre
new york le président iranien et datant
du devant les nations unies
un voyage et des questions là bas quelle
sera la teneur de son discours sera-t-il
aussi provocateur pour la communauté
internationale que ses propos du jour
pas question à ses yeux de stopper le
programme nucléaire
des mots accompagnées de symboles à
téhéran aujourd'hui des missiles longue
portée était en tête d'un défilé
militaire
gilles rabin caroline libbrecht la
parade et imposante car il s'agit de
célébrer le sacrifice des morts de la
guerre qui a opposé l'iran à l'irak de
saddam hussein dans les années 80 mais
après une semaine où la diplomatie
mondiale a tourné autour du nucléaire
iranien l'occasion était trop belle
l'iran en a profité pour montrer son
tout nouveau missile le cadre ce qui
veut dire puissance d'une portée de 1800
km dorénavant les capitale d'israël des
jt d'arabie saoudite sont à portée de
missiles iraniens mais aussi les soldats
de l'otan en afghanistan et toutes les
bases américaines dans la région
pour israël c'est toujours déclarés
prêts à empêcher par tous les moyens
l'iran d'accéder à l'armé nucléaire
c'est un tournant parce qu'il n'y a plus
de ce sentiment de sécurité absolue dont
bénéficiaient les israéliens jusqu'à
maintenant la donne a changé quand même
là je donne effectivement est en train
de changer progressivement alors que les
occidentaux négocier avec la russie et
la chine
une troisième série de sanctions le
président iranien ahmadinejad a redit ce
matin que ces sanctions n'arrêteront pas
l'iran vers ce qu'il appelle la marche
du progrès ahmadinejad qui souhaitent
ouvertement depuis deux ans qu israël
soit rayé de la carte a demandé une fois
encore le retrait d'irak des soldats des
états unis états unis qui l'a jugée trop
faible aujourd'hui pour attaquer l'iran
et ce soir le guide suprême iranien
l'ayatollah khamenei a lancé la
télévision mise en garde contre toute
attaque militaire contre son pays
certains alimenté depuis quelque temps
déjà la rumeur de la disparition de
fidel castro trois mois que le leader
cubain n'était pas apparu en public mais
castro est bien là yvan mais apparemment
fatigué christian tu as le vieux
président cubain est apparu amaigri mais
lucide après trois mois d'absence fidel
castro n'a qu'un seul message il est
bien vivant
il disait que j'étais mourant personne
ne sait quand il va mourir
l'interview a été réalisée hier après
midi
et pour le prouver le commandant en chef
indique le cours du pétrole le prix du
baril de pétrole vient d'atteindre 84 2
au cours de cet entretien d'une heure
fidel castro a notamment évoqué la
menace de guerre contre l'iran cette
réapparition met un terme aux rumeurs
sur sa mort hier hugo chavez a reconnu
pour la première fois que le leader
cubain avait failli mourir mais sans
préciser quand fidel a subi une deux
trois opérations imaginer à 80 ans il
était presque mort
il lui manque changer tout son sens les
personnes à cuba n'évoque plus le retour
de fidèles au pouvoir depuis août 2006
c'est son frère raul qui assure
l'intérim à la tête du pays
parlons de la birmanie ce pays d'asie du
sud-est est un pays pauvre sa population
souffre et elle tente de faire entendre
sa voix à la junte militaire qui la
dirige dix mille moines bouddhistes ont
même cette fois manifesté dans le pays
aujourd'hui quelques clés pour mieux
comprendre la situation de ce pays avec
philippe rochot élire giny travers ils
sont chaque jour plus nombreux
dix mille aujourd'hui à rangoon les
moines de birmanie ne baisse pas les
bras face à la junte militaire
ils protestent depuis un mois contre
l'augmentation des prix du carburant et
des transports en commun par solidarité
avec la population
aujourd'hui la police a même levé les
barrages devant la résidence surveillée
d'aung san suu kyi symbole de
l'opposition et prix nobel de la paix
très ému qui a même pu parler quelques
minutes avec les moines l'alliance des
bouddhistes et de cette femme montre que
le mouvement va au delà des simples
revendications économiques et
l'expression populaire
de plusieurs années d'une oppression de
la part du régime continue à accroître
la précarité de sa population alors même
que ce qu'on fait il ya des ressources
naturelles assez importante en birmanie
plus de la moitié des 50 millions
d'habitants vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
la junte militaire tient le pays depuis
30 ans et n'a jamais accepté la victoire
de l'alliance démocratique doc san suu
kyi aux élections de 1990 mais
aujourd'hui l'opposition est prête à
dialoguer avec les généraux les gens ont
peur
mais si le gouvernement ne veut pas de
compromis avec nous l'opposition
politique alors il n'y aura pas d'autre
alternative que la révolution pour se
protéger contre toute intervention
extérieure
la junte militaire a fait bâtir une
nouvelle capitale à 400 kilomètres de
rangoun le régime reste soutenue par la
chine el had
mais la révolte tranquille des moines
peut le faire plier
retour en france avec le baromètre du
journal du dimanche et la côte de
popularité de nicolas sarkozy qui
enregistre une baisse de 8 points à 61%
d'opinions favorables même recul pour
son premier ministre françois fillon 56
% des personnes interrogées se déclarent
satisfaites de son action soit une
baisse de 7%
un sondage ifop à paraître demain voilà
en tout cas une femme qui n'entend pas
changer parce qu'elle est devenue membre
du gouvernement ce n'est pas son genre
fadela amara entend rester libre et
cultiver sa différence la fondatrice du
mouvement ni [ __ ] ni soumises est
devenu secrétaire d'état à la ville et à
la campagne christine boutin hier à
vaulx en velin fadela amara qui avait
déjà souhaité s'attaquer à la
glandouille et elle a le sens de la
formule elle sera également je cite la
ministre des cages d'escaliers
explication de texte sur le terrain et
les nuques thierry breton autant l'une
est volubile ont sans l'autre et dit
christine boutin vole toujours un peu la
vedette à fadela amara
cette dernière préfère en rire christine
boutin sa ministre de tutelle s'est
délocalisé à lyon
fadela amara la défend à sa manière la
hausse aurait été merdique c'est de
faire telle opération de com et de venir
et dire voilà on va ressortir avec des
désaccords sa sortie mais c'est pas le
cas
un franc parler qui commence à déteindre
sur christine boutin ce qui est plus
important c'est pas le fric
ce qui est important c'est qu'on
construise si un véhicule
fadela amara le langage des cités c'est
de là qu'elle vient c'est ici qu'elle
veut changer les choses à la baisse un
seul objectif désenclaver la banlieue
sans naïveté aucune on sait qu'il ya des
groupes d'individus notamment de jeunes
mais c'est une minorité visible
agissante qui fout la merde dans la cité
et qui pas question non plus pour elle
de laisser perdurer les idées fausses
interdits mais je vois de plus en plus
de jeunes femmes voilées aujourd'hui les
problèmes de fille voilée c'est pas un
problème en soi je dirais il faut faire
attention aux mots ce qui est un
problème c'est la présence de
groupuscules islamistes
et ça c'est un vrai souci pour notre
république ministre beurette fadela
amara veut bien faire figure d'exemple
et elle promet que jamais les ors de la
république n'auront raison de ses
convictions il ya la fonction il ya la
favela parlons sécurité routière
maintenant en dix ans la baisse de la
vitesse au volant est indéniable la mise
en place de radars automatiques est pour
beaucoup
mais depuis quelques mois les mauvaises
habitudes reprennent surtout sur les
routes secondaires diego garcia à
frédéric capron personnes sur la route
la tentation d'appuyer sur le champignon
est trop forte
dommage car voici ce qui attend
l'automobiliste trop pressé
141 km heure au lieu de 90 le rappel à
l'ordre sera douloureux pour ce
conducteur
bilan quatre points a permis confisqué
pendant 72 heures en attendant une
suspension de 15 jours et jusqu'à 375
euros damende véhicule qui est rare est
fréquent je pense à des gens près d'un
accident mortel sur deux se produit sur
les départementales
mais les excès de vitesse ils restent
nombreux trop nombreux or nous avons
constaté sur le réseau souvent vers une
augmentation de 17 ans notamment du 40
km qui entraîne un retrait de permis de
produire pour le confort radar au point
les journalistes d'auto plus ont mené
une enquête dans toute la france sur les
routes secondaires plus de 60% des
conducteurs sont en infraction
pire la vitesse y a augmenté de 6 %
entre 2003 et 2007
autre sujet de préoccupation les entrées
d'agglomération
il ya un vrai problème parce que 83% des
autres même s'ils sont en infraction
ils sont en excès de vitesse effort
d'explication 8 km heure de trop en
moyenne moins de morts sur les routes le
mois dernier mais la tendance reste
inquiétante
d'après la sécurité routière un quart
des accidents mortels pourrait être
évité si tous les conducteurs à
respecter les limitations de vitesse
c'est l'étonnante question société du
jour
et si votre enfant vous réclamez un rat
un rongeur d'un genre particulier comme
animal de compagnie voilà une idée qui
fait des émules le succès du dessin
animé ratatouille n'y est pas étranger
alors comment elle s'en sortir ou
comment faire le bon choix n'éloigne est
pas les enfants la télévision laetitia
legendre mathieu berden quand elodie
veut faire plaisir à six enfants à la
sortie de l'école elle ramène duchesse
une adorable petite rade dames les gens
puissent arrêt comme ça le regarde mais
ya rien de rien d'agressif
des appréhensions ce qui leur vaut
surtout si des
c'est des personnes âgées par exemple
qui sont étonnés qui se demande si elle
voit bien ce qu'elles sont en train de
voir des choses comme ça
succès garanti matteo se faire
rapidement de nouveaux indices
essentiels dans la scène yann en tout le
monde on est mordu une manière originale
aussi de responsabiliser les enfants
futé affectueux sociable curieux de tout
et le petit animal rassemble de
nombreuses qualités
est-ce que c'est comme une coupe et un
petit rat trouve rails
on dit que ce sont mauvais non le saint
tudy gens c'est très anti nul on verra
sauf que kiev tout et que l'autre peint
compagnie 17 rats et pratiquement autant
de bébés
elodie est tombé dedans aloussi quand
elle était enfant
depuis qu'elle a ouvert son blog elle a
rencontré des dizaines de passionnés et
pas uniquement l'adolescent rebelle qui
veut faire rager ses parents c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer à des gens je
n'aurais jamais jamais rencontrés
autrement avocate qui a 12 rats dans son
grand triplex à paris ou alors la petite
mamie in 50 ans qui en a aussi
depuis que rémy le petit rongeur de
ratatouille a envahie écran leur à des
gouttes de moins en moins ces dernières
années les éleveurs se mettent même la
rate au court-bouillon afin de dénicher
de nouvelles couleurs bleu puisqu'il
homme beau et cetera le petit rongeur
deviendrait presque dur à une bête de
concours
beaucoup de gens voient encore laura
prédateurs porteurs de virus porteurs de
maladies le rat salle le rat d'égout
mais là nous sommes en présence
d'animaux extrêmement propre extrêmement
pauvres au moment des devoirs matteo
n'hésite pas à faire appel la duchesse
pour se donner du courage
avec trois ans d'espérance de vie pour
le petit rongeur ils ont le temps de se
raconter de belles histoires
à vous de choisir celle un des sports
préférés des français l'équitation vous
êtes un million à monter régulièrement à
cheval et pour tous les autres qui
souhaitent en savoir un peu plus demain
est organisée la journée du cheval
l'occasion d'aller faire un tour dans
les centres équestres comme ici au haras
de jardy dans les hauts-de-seine nicolas
le marinier et valérie lucas le poney ça
se conduit comme une mobylette
elle est pilotée 1 ça sert à rien pour
les faire avancer
saoulé de coups de cravache aux fesses
ça repart on sait pas où on s'en fout et
appelle reprend le contrôle de la
direction au haras de jardy dans les
hauts-de-seine ça fait des décennies que
l'on forme à la queue leu leu des
amoureux des chevaux
le centre équestre participent à la
journée du cheval organisée demain
l'occasion partout en france de
rencontrer des passionnés
laetitia bernard elle est non voyante et
elle est plusieurs fois championne de
france de saut d'obstacles plus que pour
n'importe qui entre elle et le cheval
c'est une question de confiance qu'ils
soient tout à fait stable dans sa tête
qui qui pètent pas un câble par dont
l'expression mais qu'ils s'y fassent pas
tout à coup absolument n'importe quoi
sans raison est-ce que je peux pas tout
contrôler pour l'accompagner aujourd'hui
andy booth ce dresseur renommée murmure
à l'oreille des chevaux c'est pas bien
bien est ralentir après talent chez vous
pour le police parce que je préfère les
chevaux pour les gens comme laetitia je
travaille vraiment un peu plus le
comportement pour que le ch vous sans
plus
un calme dans sa situation comme
aujourd'hui avant de savoir faire ça il
faudra des heures de brossage de
récurage mais bon après tout c'est aussi
du plaisir
alors demain c'est l'occasion ou jamais
de mettre le pied à l'étrier la france
du rugby a retrouvé le sourire hier soir
sourire crispé en première mi temps puis
sourire sincère lors d'un fabuleux coup
de pied de frédéric michalak solide et
solidaire le quinze de france était au
rendez vous profitons de cet instant
avant de penser à l'avenir et à des
adversaires de l'hémisphère sud
manuel tissier jean yves blanc
au lendemain du cri de victoire du stade
de france les bleus ont retrouvé leur
compagnie un peu de sérénité
un seul blessé bernard laporte incapable
de marcher après une entorse à la
cheville mais pas de quoi gâcher le
plaisir la fe corp et c'est pour ça que
l'issue du match
ouais c'est vrai qu' on était on était
satisfait il ya dans les vestiaires de
voir que il y avait des sourires 14
millions de français attendait le réveil
des bleus aux quatre coins du pays
écran géant à bordeaux barbon des arènes
au paris marseille est partout
et le quinze de france a fait patienter
ses supporters jusqu'à l'heure de jeu
avant cette passe lumineuse de michalak
les français ne menaient que grâce aux
pénalités d'elissalde
mais l'essai de vincent clerc libère la
nation et son futur secrétaire d'état
l'irlande a un genou à terre et les fans
la tête déjà au prochain match
le second essai tricolore vient encore
d'un coup de pied toulousain elissalde
trouve vincent clerc qui m'a en
puissance 25 3 les bleus sont sortis du
piège et peuvent maintenant se rêver à
un destin de footballeur champion du
monde ils ont pu s'installer au but
alors contre le paraguay ils sont allés
aux penaltys contre l'italie ils ont mis
3 3 0 au brésil se dire c'est pour ça
qu'ils à rien de les protéger de gagner
les matches de se qualifier parce que
sur lie perdu hier c'était dramatique
quoi il y avait bien un air de l'été 98
hier soir même si tout le monde n'a pas
pu danser comme il l'aurait souhaité
bernard laporte boîte mais ces bleus ont
trouvé le rythme
ils ont quartier libre jusqu'à mardi
avant de repartir du bon pied pour
affronter la géorgie et que s'est il
passé aujourd'hui sur les terrains de la
coupe du monde l'angleterre apparaît
toujours en difficulté malgré sa
victoire du jour julien benedetto il
s'en est fallu d'un cheveu pour que la
surprenante équipe des îles tonga ne
crée le premier exploit de cette coupe
du monde
archi-favorite l'afrique du sud choisi
d'aligner ses remplaçants péché
d'orgueil après cet essai en force
les polynésiens même 10 à 7 en début de
deuxième mi temps l'entraîneur des
springboks ce envoie alors ses meilleurs
joueurs sur le terrain et là ça déménage
trois essais en dix minutes
l'afrique du sud s'envole au score 27 10
il reste dix minutes à jouer
les joueurs du pacifique se ruaient
alors à l'attaqué ils marquent deux
essais coup sur coup
l'afrique du sud tremble mais gagne
finalement 30 25
les tonga arraché un précieux point de
bonus ils joueront leur place en quarts
de finale dans un match couperet contre
l'angleterre
les champions du monde humilié par
l'afrique du sud ont battu cet après
midi difficilement les samoa 44 à 22 le
quinze de la rose inscrit quatre essais
et retrouve son arme absolue
jonny wilkinson auteur de 24 points cet
après midi prochain match contre les
tonga
victoire impérative pour l'angleterre
sinon elle sera éliminée du football
maintenant et la ligue 1 et la série
noire continue en championnat de france
pour l'olympique de marseille
après les belles soirées de la ligue des
champions l'om rechute à auxerre défaite
de but à 0 allez marseillais pour
l'anecdote ont dû jouer avec le
troisième maillot des auxerrois
voilà deuxième but auxerrois ce soir les
autres rencontres monaco se déplace à
valenciennes lens à toulouse en
attendant demain psg bordeaux et lyon
lille demain n'oubliez pas à midi france
de foot et de nivelles bière images et
analyses et reportages dans les
coulisses de la ligue 1 une fin de
journal pour les petits et pour les
grands la passion des jeux vidéo n'a pas
d'âge la france s'impose de plus en plus
comme un pays créatif en la matière il
lui fallait donc sa vitrine et son
festival
au programme les dernières nouveautés à
découvrir le temps d'un week end à
montreuil en banlieue parisienne
emmanuel lambert chloé cormery
ses portes sfr mmorpg pour nous c'est du
charabia pour eux c'est toute leur vie
aujourd'hui les fondus du pixel étaient
tous au festival du jeu vidéo
luc lui ne sait plus où donner de la
tête il a fait 700 kilomètres pour voir
tout ça les nouveautés
sur des écrans très bonne qualité pour
l'intéressée que je vais acheter
demandez des créateurs d
70 tentes plusieurs centaines de
consoles et d'ordinateurs une chose est
sûre la crème de l'industrie
vidéoludique est là pour charmer même
les plus petits
ambiance gothique ses fans attendent un
jeu de rôle depuis des mois ils vont
enfin pouvoir jouer en avant première
tout est
j'ai tué
non
or de jouer un rôle salon comme celui ci
permet aussi de découvrir des objets un
peu fou comme ce ballon joystick
autre accessoire extrêmement intéressant
le siège mais qu'ils vont s'y cassa
prendre place dans le salon
mais les sensations sont extrêmement
étonnante
la grande différence avec d'autres
salons un concours qui récompense les
jeux français expérience en 12 jeux
d'aventuré rafler la mise
meilleur jeu grand prix du jury meilleur
scénario dans la technologie diriger les
jeux il fallait qu'ils aient plus de 6
ou plus de sa vallée par des exploits
maintenant je vais vraiment on le juge
sur les émotions qu'il procure
des jeunes ultra réaliste pour tous les
âges pour tous les goûts c'est sur la
vie en trois dimensions et l'industrie
du jeu vidéo ont de beaux jours devant
elle
cela fait près de 30 ans que l'amérique
n'avait pas rendu hommage à l'un de ses
plus grands peintres edward hopper une
rétrospective lui est enfin consacré en
ce moment à washington aux peurs qui a
su saisir ces instantanés de la vie
quotidienne souvent empreints de
mélancolie comme son célèbre tableau
représentant un couple attablé au
comptoir d'un bar la nuit regardez alain
de chalvron aaron dimon c'est un des
tableaux les plus connus au monde
mille fois reproduit nighthawk les
noctambules des doigts d'europe le clou
d'une exposition exceptionnelle à la
national gallery de washington
les principales oeuvres du plus célèbre
des peintres américains sont là peintre
de la solitude de l'incommunicabilité
ces visages perdu dans le vide le
silence
on les retrouve dans la plupart des
toiles tristesse de ces femmes dans des
chambres d'hôtel un peu glauque
ces femmes ou plutôt cette femme c'est
toujours la même sa propre épouse unique
modèle edward hopper est avant tout un
peintre d'atmosphère ses meilleurs temps
tu racontes pratiquement une histoire
dont on doit trouver la fin de même ses
tableaux font appel à notre imagination
quand aucun autre peintre figuratif il
sait le faire
que se passe-t-il dans ce couple qui n'a
plus rien à se dire et dans ce bureau la
secrétaire cherche-t-elle à aguicher son
patron faussement plongé dans ses
papiers
à quoi pensait touvre heureuse dans un
théâtre à moitié vide
qu'est-ce qui ronge cette femme perdue
dans ce bar minable
les toiles de hopper se regarde comme
des films qu'on se fait dans la tête son
art a été très influencé par le cinéma
mais lui-même influencé les cinéastes
dès qu'il est devenu célèbre par la
qualité de sa peinture par exemple dans
les années 40-50 hitchcock dans le xi
cause a été inspirée par les paysages de
hopper la vie de repères qui sait pas
lui-même à deux reprises n'a pourtant
rien de glauque il a connu le succès à
40 entre les deux guerres immense succès
et une vie privée sans à coup et
pourtant harper pas presse
dans la douleur difficile de dire
comment me vient l'inspiration mais
c'est un processus lent une lente
gestation dans ma tête qui aboutit à une
émotion je suppose
aucun artiste n'a autant influencé la
société américaine les cinéastes on l'a
vu les décorateurs les écrivains ses
confrères tous doivent quelque chose
harper je n'ai jamais connu d'artistes
qui n'aimait pas aux peurs tout le monde
danse que c'était le meilleur
il était comme un dieu cette exposition
n'est pas seulement un plaisir
esthétique c'est un choc émotionnel une
visite dans un monde épais et pourtant
familier vivement qu'elle traverse
l'atlantique on retourne à cette
information que je vous donnais en début
de ce journal à mort d'une fillette de
dix ans après avoir été agressé par deux
chiens à auteuil près de beauvais dans
l'oise
on retrouve amaury guibert sur place
bonsoir amaury la ministre de
l'intérieur michèle alliot marie vient
de réagir ce soir à la mort de l'enfant
je crois oui tout à fait laurent michèle
alliot marie a tenu à réagir en
rappelant qu'elle entendait durcir la
législation concernant les chiens
dangereux en insistant notamment sur la
formation des maîtres le texte devrait
être proposé dès la semaine prochaine
il faut savoir que les chiens impliqué
dans ce drame sont des dogues allemands
et que eux ne sont pas classés comme
chiens dangereux donc peut-être qu'une
réflexion va être lancée pour revoir
cette classification
ce drame s'est joué vers 10 vers 16
heures cet après-midi la fillette âgée
de 10 ans jouait dans le jardin qui se
trouve derrière moi avec les deux chiens
qui appartenait à sa mère et à la mère
et aux compagnons la mer était resté à
l'intérieur de la maison quand elle a
entendu des cris elle s'est
immédiatement précipité à l'extérieur
mais il était trop tard la fillette
était très grièvement blessée elle est
décédée peu après des suites de ses
blessures les deux chiens ont pu être
maîtrisé par les gendarmes ils ont été
amenés à la fourrière de beauvais et
devrait être très probablement utah
nasier aux termes de l' enquête
merci pour toutes ces précisions enfin
sedan
hier hommage rendu aujourd'hui à jean
françois bizot a paris une messe était
célébrée en la mémoire du fondateur de
la revue actuelle et de radio nova
jean françois bizot était une grande
figure de la contre-culture et c'était 1
le 8 septembre dernier à l'âge de 63 ans
avant de terminer ce journal l'image du
jour celle des joueurs français qui ont
retrouvé le sourire après leur victoire
hier soir face à l'irlande journée de
repos et barbecue aujourd'hui avant de
se reconcentrer sur la suite de cette
coupe du monde l'objectif encore et
toujours évité la nouvelle zélande en
quart de finale voilà pour la qulité de
ce samedi merci à vous d'avoir suivi ce
journal je vous retrouve demain pour
l'information dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez 20h50 le plus grand
cabaret du monde présenté par patrick
sébastien passé une très belle soirée à
demain